[Musique]
alors christophe castaner at il eu
raison de refuser d'interdire les
manifestations en faveur d'adama traoré
manif lancé notamment par sos racisme ce
soir la décision en tous les cas du
ministre de l'intérieur le refus du
ministre de l'intérieur est très
commentée sur le site du figaro le
ministre de l'intérieur français run il
est adroit se sont notamment certains de
vos commentaires autre commentaire celui
que j'ai retrouvé qu'on a retrouvés cet
après midi sur les forums du client au
donc nos petits commerces bistrot salles
de concerts théâtres et cinémas peuvent
je cite crever en paix pendant que des
milliers de personnes se réunissent en
toute impunité
en pleine crise du coc vide où est la
morale où est la logique
en tous les cas il y à un autre
sentiment c'est l'émotion qui a avant de
voir d'avoir votre réaction
et bien je vous propose d'écouter les
explications du ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner
je crois que l'émotion mondiale qui est
une émotion scène sur ce sujet dépasse
au fond les règles juridiques qui
s'applique j'invite chacun à faire
attention à pratiquer les gestes
barrière mais nous ne souhaitons pas
réaffirmé l'interdiction qui est de
droit qui est de fait et il n'y aura pas
de sanction et de procès verbal pour la
participation à cette manifestation soit
ce qui est des moments font comprendre
que cette émotion là et je le redis kate
une émotion forte positive elle puisse
être soutenue
l'autre coup de théâtre aujourd'hui ça a
été ces dernières entre les cas
l'humiliation infligée par la famille
traoré elle refuse d'être reçus par la
ministre de la justice nicole belloubet
voici ce qu'en pense le conseil des
gendarmes qui avaient interpellé adama
traoré des pressions en pressions une
plus loire je ne sont pas qualifiées de
faibles mais qui panique un peu décide
de recevoir la famille est là quand je
dis raffinement dans le sadisme cette
même famille qui met la pression du
moment tout compte fait c'est pas vie
nous recevoir
c'est une violation effective de la
séparation des pouvoirs et donc on
ajoute à la pression l'humiliation et je
trouve ça une période mais une fréquence
absolument qu'est la mythologie une
séquence absolument calamiteuse laurence
taillade
est-ce que castaner et belloubet
pouvait-il faire autrement que ce qu'ils
ont fait ben écoute et enfin j'espère
qu'ils pouvaient faire autrement parce
que quand on est ministre on a
théoriquement toutes les manettes en
l'occurrence on va prendre les choses
séparément d'un côté effectivement on a
un castaner qui est très très faible
face à ce qui n'est aujourd'hui
peut-être vous devrez respecter déjà la
loi sont romain il est ministre de
l'intérieur il est censé faire appliquer
les lois et on se rend compte qu'il est
grand mère qui vont acheter le pain qui
vont payer sous 35 euros damende quand
des manifestations il ya une semaine
c'était des sans papiers et donc des
perspectives à la plus totale illégalité
qui fuyait dans paris la veut ce sont
des soutiens à la famille traoré le bon
c'est une affaire qui est plus ou moins
en cours mais en l'occurrence il ya
aucune raison de décider de se faire
justice soi même dans la rue et on ne
fait rien et on peut être
particulièrement choqué d'autant plus
que madame belloubet agi posture la
demande du président de la république
donc il faut quand même noter qui
finalement valu de l'anglais de
rencontrer des personnes qui sont
directement impliqués dans un bosquet et
là effectivement il ya une confusion
puisqu'il y a
il y a normalement c'est peu passion des
pouvoirs et on marche complètement sur
la tête on s'interdit de respecter la
séparation des pouvoirs madame dubé est
complètement à côté de la plaque
quant à logis de cette façon là j'ai
même envie de dire que ce soit monsieur
questionnaire ou madame b louper ils
sont en train de mettre la république à
genoux alors christophe castaner nicole
belloubet son tentera de mettre la
république à genou sébastien pots-de-vin
est ce que notamment le ministre de
l'intérieur a eu raison de deux refusé
d'interdire ces manifestations il faut
quand même regarder un petit peu ce qui
se passe au niveau européen voire au
niveau mondial c'est à dire que la
manifestation ce soir c'est surtout une
manifestation en hommage à georges klein
et des manifestations il y en a à madrid
à montréal à rome à londres à bristol à
bruxelles au pays dans les pays et bah
copenhague bieber budapest j'en passe
encore donc on voit bien que le sujet de
la manifestation ce soir il dépasse le
cadre français que du coup cette
question de oui ou non interdire sans au
fond avoir de mesures de coercition à
cette interdiction qui auront la
position christophe castaner est quelque
chose qui est une dynamique ja lire
internationale dont de mon point de vue
pense pas que ça ne pose pas un problème
ça pose plus de problème du côté de
nicole belloubet puisque effectivement
il y a
actuellement quand même une affaire une
instruction est de voir lire des
somistes de la justice recevoir une
famille ça pose quand même plus de
difficultés pour dire les choses
simplement donc on peut pas mélanger les
deux de mon point de vue c'est à dire
que je pense que d'un côté que cette
affaire a bien fait parce qu'on voit
très bien qui est un élément un élan
puissant pro fort et qu' il vaut mieux
parfois essayé d'aller ton sens de ces
élans pour pas être à côté de dynamique
historique et de l'autre côté il ya une
problématique d'une garde des sceaux qui
effectivement a je pense fait une erreur
voire une faute
sébastien c'est nicole belloubet qui a
commis une faute mais sébastien conteste
l'idée de laurence laurence penser que
castaner était à côté de la plaque
ce qui n'est pas l'avis de sébastien qui
est dans la dynamique est votre avis vos
gabriel cluzel oui alors moi ça ne va
pas vous étonner d'un avis tout à fait
opposé à celui qui vient d'être exposé
car je trouve que en réalité c'est une
grave erreur de la part de christophe
castaner de précisément rentrer dans la
rhétorique de la famille traoré
consistant à dire que adama traoré et
d'orge floyd sont les une seule et même
victime finalement parce que c'est dire
implicitement que la police française
et comme la police américaine que les
problématiques raciale voire racialiste
américaines sont tout à fait call câble
en france ce qui est évidemment
complètement faux s'est surtout montré
que il de façon extraits que la tente il
yad'autres france dans ce pays à une
france que que l'on veuille oui et c'est
à dire eh bien la france d'aider par
exemple des gilet jaune alors là on n'a
pas peur de réprimer les manifestations
j'ai remarqué que pour les mâles et
manifestations récentes
il n'y a pas eu de tirs de l bd par
exemple et d'ailleurs y arrive du tout
les a laissés faire et puis à la france
évidemment des restaurateurs des parents
des kicks et auxquels on impose des de
ceux qui pratiquent leur religion si
auxquels on impose des règles assez
ubuesque de distanciation physique comme
on dit maintenant
mais à la compagnie au double décimètre
tandis que d'autres alors là ils peuvent
pas seul à se rassembler à plus de 10
mes enfants vont à l'école une matinée
sur deux parce qu'ils peuvent être pas
plus de 10 dans la classe ou 15 je crois
est en revanche d'autres peuvent se
rassembler non pas 200 à 2000 mais à
20000 donc effective donc cesser c'est
absolument redoutable il ya une
partition du territoire n'ont pas
géographique mais juridique finalement
et ça envoie un signal tout à fait
détestable et puis l'excusent de
christophe castaner
je dois dire est assez là aussi ubuesque
puisqu'il a dit il ya des moments de
l'émotion dépasse les règles juridiques
alors ça vraiment je pense que c'est un
morceau d'anthologie et est dommage qu
on ne l'est pas su quand on limite l
assistance aux enterrements
ces dernières semaines non je crois
alors maintenant est-ce qu'il a une
raison je crois surtout qu'il n'a pas eu
le choix parce qu'il a très peur que les
banlieues s'embrase et donc il n'a
trouvé que cette solution là faire
profil bas plutôt que de prendre le
problème à bras le corps qu'il aurait
exposé à peut-être quelques grammes
difficulté ou en tout cas des choix
politiques difficiles pour lui arnaud
benedetti est ce que justement si l'on
écoute je la voyais avec l'usld elle
c'était la seule solution que pouvait
avoir christophe castaner pour éviter
d'un embrasement dans les banlieues
est-ce que quel que soit ce qu'on en
pense
ça peut justement avoir cette efficacité
là et ça peut avoir cet effet là éviter
un embrasement dans des quartiers
sensibles
en tout cas manifestement c'est
certainement l'une des motivations qui
ne explique la position du ministre de
l'intérieur
mais cette position ne sera certainement
pas comprise par une grande partie de
l'opinion publique
si vous voulez pour qu'un état soit
respectée il faut qu'il soit rationnelle
et en l'occurrence ceux qui manquent
fondamentalement dans le discours du
ministre du ministre de l'intérieur et
le discours de l'exécutif c'est la
rationalité vous ne pouvez pas avoir
d'un côté la ministre de la santé qui
tous les matins nous rappelle qu'il faut
être extrêmement prudent qui veut même
d'une certaine manière en tout cas qui
donne le sentiment de prendre toutes les
précautions qui ralentissent même d'une
certaine façon le déconfinement et d'un
côté un ministre de l'intérieur qui
autorise
les manifestations qui viennent à
l'encontre des consignes qui sont amples
et des par l'exécutif vous vous imaginez
que ce type d'injonctions paradoxales
créer dans l'opinion une incompréhension
absolue à cela il faut quand même être
aussi je crois assez clair et direct
aujourd'hui il ya dans ces
manifestations dans ces mobilisations
qui sont certes légitimes dans
l'expression de l'émotion qu'elle
manifeste vis-à-vis du cas de
minneapolis il y a aussi dans ses
mouvements et dans ces mobilisations un
rapport de force qui est instaurée par
un certain nombre de groupements
politiques que l'on connaît bien qui
finalement se saisisse de la cause
américaine pour véhiculer tout autre
message dans le modèle républicain
français il ya si vous voulez là aussi
un autre une autre une autre une autre
contradiction
vous pouvez pas tenir un discours
d'autorité comme monsieur castaner
souhaite le tenir et de développer
notamment lorsque il
comme l'a dit d'ailleurs gabriac uzel à
juste titre quand il s'adressait au
gilet jaune et avoir un discours qui
finalement traduit une faiblesse
qui est tout à fait évidente lorsque
d'autres groupes manifestent
il ya là une contradiction qui me
semble-t-il est extrêmement dangereuse
pour l'avenir et qui politiquement la
séquence que l'on vit aura des
conséquences dans la structuration de
l'opinion publique
je pense que en effet l'état lorsqu'il
est contraint lorsqu'il est en
contradiction montre qu'il est faible
alors une réduction des injonctions
contradictoires est ce que c'est ce que
vous ressentez c'est en tout cas ce que
nous viennent nous dire à l'instant
arnaud benedetti en tout cas je vous
salue vous êtes nombreux à nous avoir
rejoints notamment sur le chat du figaro
avec la modération de l'oea fournier je
salue christophe je salue thucydide je
salue maxine et cm également babineau et
christian léon justement il y à une
question qui est posée notamment par
maxime sachant que christophe castaner
lui ce matin ce ne se dit pas opposé à
cette idée
est-ce que macro on va se mettre à
genoux est-ce que macron doit se mettre
à genoux comme se sont mis à genoux des
centaines de policiers des centaines
d'américains
le candidat à la halle au challenger de
donald trump le démocrate joe biden
sébastien pots de vin c'est intéressant
nous parler de cela parce que vous
mettez bien en avant le fait donc que
cette réunion de cette manifestation de
ce soir elle dépasse les cadres français
est donc là on n'est pas simplement
4' intéressant parce que vous faites le
lien vous même bien permettez moi comme
moi je pense que si on peut se permettre
un tout petit peu de complexité de temps
en temps je sais que c'est pas bien je
sais que c'est beaucoup mieux que je
tapais les uns contre les autres et
d'avoir une france facturée parce que
c'est intéressant ça fait vendre des
bouquins c'est super mais un tout petit
peu de complexité là pour le coup ce
soir c'est pas simplement une question
d'alain traoré d'accord donc s'il faut
tout de suite que je dise que je suis
contre les indigènes
ceux qui peuvent éventuellement essayer
d' infiltrer les manifestations je les
dix membres du printemps républicain je
n'ai pas de problème avec ça
les choses sont claires elles 110 par
contre si on veut simplement limiter la
manifestation de ce soir au canada mal
traoré alors là je pense qu'on fait une
grossière erreur parce que quand ça se
passe en espagne au québec on était du
royaume uni en belgique au danemark en
suède en hongrie aux pays-bas
c'est pas le cas la dame traoré on est
bien d'accord ou alors il ya une
internationale indigéniste qui est
derrière tout cela
donc ce que j'essaie de d'expliquer dans
cette vision que l'on a c'est qu'il y à
un mouvement de fond et ce mouvement de
fond est ce qu'on y réponde
ou est-ce qu'on n'y répond pas et oui ça
va facturer l'opinion publique durera
donc durablement sur surtout s'ils n'y
répondent pas mais il faut y répondre
avec un tout petit peu de complexité à
savoir quand la police il y a en son
sein des brebis galeuses qui ne
respectent pas les droits les plus
élémentaires
je vous renvoie à ce qu'a dit récemment
tania de montaigne je vous renvoie à la
tribune de corinne narassiguin ce matin
notamment qui répondait allergiques des
portes sur sur les questions de mondial
de suprématie blanche
on voit bien que la problématique est
complexe
donc si on peut éviter juste pour une
fois de simplifier les choses et d'y
mettre un peu de complexité je suis
certain que nos points de vue sur
d'autant plus fort et qu'on fera avancer
le sujet une règle sauf peut-être
laurent tailhade justement cette cette
idée qui est défendu par sébastien
pots-de-vin autour de fait que c'est
complexe et donc que les manifestations
de ce soir sont légitimes dans la mesure
où elles s'inscrivent dans une
mobilisation internationale pour lutter
contre le racisme
je remercie de remarquer que finalement
on doit être un peu idiote à comprendre
que pour nous ce soit un problème juste
avant qu'elle accouche mans parce que
malheureusement les
c'est qu' il n'y aura bien un
rapprochement entre le cas traoré et le
cas george clooney dans notre pays et
entendre dire que c'est que ça et qu'il
faut réfléchir
moi je vois ce qui se passe dans mon
pays et pour répondre à votre question
il est hors de question d'accepter qu'un
président de la république il n'est pas
que emmanuel macron il incarne la
république française et à ce titre là un
président de la république n'a pas à
poser un genou à terre c'est lui qui
porte l'ensemble de nos institutions sur
son dos et donc je pense que la question
elle est très simple on n'a pas à être
fier systématiquement dans un réflexe de
victimes à colombes puisque c'est c'est
ça qu'on nous reproche les générations
actuelles qui sont dans notre pays qui
sont des descendants d'immigrés sont
français au même titre que les français
de souche aime pas ce terme ils sont
même titre que les français de souche et
donc il n'y a aucune raison que les uns
s'excuse de ce que des générations
antérieures a en fait à d'autres parce
que sinon on n'en finit pas donc c'est
pas comme ça qu'on va réussir à avancer
et surtout qu'on va réussir à créer et à
recréer une unité nationale parce que je
rappelle quand même pour des ans un pays
un et indivisible et 7 indivisibilité on
ne peut que la fracture est en
reconnaissant un certain nombre de
choses et pas d'autres donc si on veut
revenir à une indivisibilité de l'état
est bon on restaure un état fort on
arrête d'avoir des attitudes
discriminante dans le sens on autorise
certaines choses pour pertes certaines
populations et pas pour d'autres et on
est impartiale sur la façon d'appliquer
la loi no ça notamment quand il s'agit
de la couleur de peau ou de la religion
en l'occurrence moi je constate qu'il ya
discrimination dans la façon d'appliquer
la loi et notamment ce soir pourquoi
parce qu'effectivement monsieur castaner
apport a peur donc c'est comme ça qu'on
fracturé la finale la république
c'est justement en n'étant pas impartial
dans la façon d'appliquer la loi alors
nos internautes chez vous êtes à peu
divisé alors une large majorité
vous êtes plutôt du point de vue vous
partagez plus tôt les points de vue qui
vient d'être exprimées notamment par
laurence tahri taillade je cite
notamment sébastien bérubé castaner sa
liste la france et les français
christophe 78 ce gouvernement donne
raison à celles et ceux qui ne
respectent pas la rue de la loi
thucydide quel internaute pas d'historia
il n'a eu que 23000 n'y a eu que 23
mille manifestants et le pouvoir cède
c'est fou gens qui nous dit sur facebook
castaner doit démissionner les
interdictions de manifester ne sont pas
appliquées et rien n'est fait même pas
de plainte contre les organistes contre
les organisateurs pourtant un million de
dégâts pardon je découvre les
commentaires en même temps en revanche
babineau lui pense comme sébastien
justin trudeau s'est mis à genoux merkel
a condamné fermement je suis d'accord
avec monsieur pots-de-vin c'est un
phénomène mondial
et puis max m qui nous dit qui dit
également bravo sébastien et c'est m
en revanche qui vient de me dire bravo
madame donc c'était pour vous laurence
laurent tailhade donc on va regarder un
petit peu là les réponses à la question
qu'on vient de poser sur qu'on a posés
sur twitter après vais vous le refus
approuvez-vous le refus de christophe
castaner d'interdire la manifestation de
la soirée ce racisme ce soir est de 60%
un peu plus de 60% des internautes
n'approuve pas ce la position de
christophe castaner 37% oui vous allez
voir les résultats sont encore plus
forts sur la question d'après qu'on va
vous poser
de toute façon on reviendra sur cette
mobilisation ce soir les images soient
retrouvées en tout cas sur le site le
nouveau portail de figaro live qu'on est
heureux de vous montrer plus aéré plus
dynamique
enfin on va pouvoir s'y retrouver un
petit peu plus où vous pouvez voir ce
direct en même temps que vous pouvez le
voir sur la page d'accueil du figaro est
ainsi que sur facebook depuis 1958 le
niveau n'a jamais été aussi bas on a vu
tout seul toutes sortes de choses toutes
sortes d'affaires des coups bas des
coups tordus des manoeuvres mais un
niveau de débats et de propositions de
propositions aussi délétère jamais la
cinquième touche le fond alors c'est la
conviction d'être d'un d'entre vous
c'est la conviction d'un internaute du
figaro qui s'appelle junger on demandera
d'ailleurs à la renommée des ti
rédacteur en chef de la revue
parlementaire ce qui